Abby call you back thank you very much
never Sherman
Louisa you're [ __ ] right into your
Twitter for the militia no my twitter is
how about our own six for one month and
this is a gift for meeting you guys for
the office
oh [ __ ] have you ever seen this with the
deep from G purple no Gillian Gillian
Wow they got really close up one night
because they were supposed to have
Robert Plant joined Sabbath after dia
but you know the record company would
like well if we can't getting in who do
you guys want
let's talk again Gillan season you want
to do it they got buttered up sign a
contract at a bar and then just record
an album
oh it's horrible they have online
bedroom his eyes
yeah with eating Gillan think of a [ __ ]
yeah Hamid it's [ __ ] terrible again
this does he
you know what you're trying to take on
me or some other [ __ ] yes pretty bad but
there's like a couple tress on I heard
it I heard there's a couple tracker he's
saying here we go people it's a
Wednesday night you wanted it you
[ __ ] got it
all the staying close by the way it's
gonna fly the climate you didn't bring
the hummus a little bit drop in the
hummus he chickened out his idea here
before others let me see I wrote how
much more memory and I play some people
own why you put it to you you'll [ __ ]
you gonna call the top are already ready
I've know an Iranian restaurant sitting
next to looking on a buddy shall we go
my god
[Music]
this is your night [ __ ] this is
going to get ugly tonight hospital bills
meningitis forgetting everything tonight
where we shadows here my main man being
the ridley did music all the [ __ ] way
tonight with your Nadine hang up right
now [ __ ] I ain't gonna get no
better poignant holy [ __ ] I told you you
had some [ __ ] commend moving around
why actually got to go down pretty funny
for original print scene you're doing go
crazy of it lock up your kids put the
kids in the closet
if yong-dae teen hang up now and then
gotta get no better for you tonight
we're gonna open up with lead to
insomnia completely I gotta go Ellie all
right quit it guys Nicola first which
one the guy who I except they're here I
have no idea come with a long interest
Oh [ __ ] edge it was part of the
band the hell is Ozzy al-assad you
another win you know
we got everything tonight mint stars
[ __ ] mushroom we got everything
[Music]
[Laughter]
look at this [ __ ] beauty and look at
this oh [ __ ] here we go
look how little that bong is okay I'm
taking K you will go on mic tonight
because we're super second yeah but I'll
trust you like anyone said you were
coughing and drooling that's okay that's
what I wanted to this this might be like
cabana [ __ ] right here I feel [ __ ]
Hitler's dogs into this [ __ ] right here
let's go oh wow
get that muley kick that [ __ ]
merely that's the one over there yo
opening up early time all goods in the
Sammy long hot look at this [ __ ] to lay
his head hasn't been this running my
you're gonna weary cuz I've been a bad
bad boy I told you this [ __ ]
commander country off the skinny Rizzy
so you feel this is from the one I jus
this is [ __ ]
that are cooking [ __ ] like eight
years to get the zoo right so you
finally got it
why you feel it with you the goose is in
your [ __ ]
you
and everything with the whole you know
you think of you know our work comes
with her you see the [ __ ] two
important in your next you feel like you
having a stroke this is the weed you
need right here this is the wig that you
need ready
you bad [ __ ]
Wednesday night July the 5th the 4th of
July is over but you still got those
firecrackers
we don't need firecrackers here we're
coming at you from all directions what's
this
bamm-bamm put it [ __ ]
we're throwing heat for more [ __ ]
levels it's a party no matter how your
[ __ ] clothes look at this [ __ ] but
BAM [ __ ] that's how we're rolling on
the bull do loud tonight storming into
Vegas Friday morning
South Pointe casino Friday night be
there be square 7:30 you're out of there
by 9:00 you take an old ball with a Joe
Rogan an al you're nice complete you get
a dose of uncle Joey and Dean del Drizzy
and then you get a [ __ ] dose of Joe
Rogan and Hogan's [ __ ] heroes it's
over what up Lisa I asked and don't
forget the main attraction look at it
we're not even doing stars tonight still
chocolate night tonight here
nice two pieces four pieces you break it
up it's a spearmint it's called spaceman
mint are you [ __ ] kidding me or what
when was the last time you were [ __ ]
spaceman and mentok veneers anyway I'm
feeling homesick Hamza I had a good day
couple good meetings I wrote the [ __ ]
you Jitsu was very intense today but I
keep going I keep showing up I suck but
I keep showing up and don't matter I'll
catch your [ __ ] the Reebok
what's going on anyway
well Rhys you Alvarado is here looking
like [ __ ] Bon Jovi in 87 and I'm
saying
[Music]
there you go look at that [ __ ] fog of
death coming at you that's how we're
rolling tonight I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't get listen we uncle broke his
ankle two weeks ago go over there steal
his regulars tie them up take the bikes
let's do some beers let's get this party
started right - [ __ ] I want to give a
shout-out to my main man
Jean Castro sending me [ __ ] albums
today t-shirts I love you change your
bad [ __ ]
Gordon Warnock sent me two books the art
of war for writing and also Bruce Lee
[ __ ] memorabilia type deadly [ __ ]
things anyway and my man was the other
shirt he sent us some goodies in the
mail today - that's the type of party
this is but listen if you wanted to Joey
if I'm on the chip a chaplain what's
that one that's my other dog pick some
of this [ __ ] here Maurice in her life
fill this up right here this is the [ __ ]
that killed Carrie Fisher captain there
Jack the bear there he is my dog anyway
let's get this party started Lee we got
an ID to [ __ ] around here did you read
them it I hope you did look at this oh
yeah
tremendous minty things like Listerine
with chocolate over the mountain we
don't get all dressed up before over
your face will like it delicious trying
that bright your little Mexican
restaurants you little clock at min time
when I came in one down one to go
will hitting this [ __ ] hard
tonight one piece for each I want to
start with that position
[ __ ] yeah I guess we're opening up the
stars to the night so it's a chocolate
star type of evening hey go Mauricio 125
and there's more for you you want 10
whenever you want my brush want some
water thank you got there
here we go Damon disease diet mmm
bicolored mmm
one down one to go
[Music]
David the good you named in the salmon
nobody knows but I know you know who
named his son David James Caan is a
thief when they adopted the gift from
the hooker like they called them David
Haye trivia [ __ ] facts here all day
long people oh [ __ ] look at Mauricio
Corrado showing up with the track
Giorgio's Marana rather than george on
the laundry who is a tangerine [ __ ]
dream Jesus one of the greatest movies
of the 80s one that Khan Film Festival
we ain't [ __ ] around in if you ain't
deep into James Caan with this one this
is ugly right here that's what I'm
talking about Mauricio always shows up
prepared with all the good you
understand me he's a good man to have on
your [ __ ] right look he's over they
said Lee
you want to start to break it up a
little bit sure why not
here we go package number two how was
that wait Maurice you want to bond this
one all right dad that has to get them
to come down bigger than that we is
going to be always make splitter alright
it's always all right
you live your make it for the next day
we have a good time right or wrong what
would you be doing at home watching our
in the black googling restaurants that
suck dick and usual kinam unbelievable
there you go
chopper morning team spirit lovers
[Music]
Tallyho [ __ ] if you want to be
picked off a GU you gotta hit ship ship
Tallyho first and this is how you get
they understand me do me a favor we
should open that cake for [ __ ] up
already
don't open press five five five five
[Music]
half put it down we're going deep
tonight ladies and gentlemen be [ __ ]
around
you still got another one left there
with your name on it he's yelling at you
that one
I'm happy you doing this tonight so good
but blue fun podcast we haven't been
this is it's gonna work together I miss
you guys I hope you had a happy fourth I
hope you didn't lose a finger
don't go away I'm playing BJ oh that's
one of my hats don't go away
oh yeah oh yeah
Oh Maurice is gone what you got dog
deshaun falling for Oh
oh [ __ ] the party's beginning one down
one more piece it's over that's it and
it's delicious I don't give a [ __ ]
delicious nutritious low and called
no sugar and 250 milligrams of up way
free [ __ ] and it's also gluten free
you know these who takes care you like
me [ __ ] I'm saying I'm like I
think like three but who gives a [ __ ]
wait watches people to leave marijuana
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah don't [ __ ] around fire what
the drives over his in the real [ __ ]
savages come on or you [ __ ] who
you spoke with yesterday good sucked
muck dick you understand me tonight the
night when savages go up I got a [ __ ]
roman candle I got a little misled blood
to hand walk what from a felon that was
always beat tonight understanding [ __ ]
em all up that's right I see you got a
gun the handball court the best guns at
your local half walk home I bought a gun
that I don't miss got like 80 to kill
you can be blind and shoot somebody with
the gun he's gonna hollered out there's
always the education of every soul fella
you want to buy a gun go to handball
court those are the best weapons
available to you and I went down the
corner right by the gun yeah we [ __ ]
thing to do
yes the package for the felons a half
like felon child molestin [ __ ]
yellow watch it it's like a [ __ ] back
there you got to be careful as icon it's
like a [ __ ] you you ever see sons of
anarchy
right before Gemma leave town when Jax
you're the killer
[ __ ] you and the spoiler just Loki if
eight years get together she goes to a
school to see a grandson that's cool if
you look the camera that way that samba4
that's cool is waiting on the court
she's the church at the church that's on
the corner and then they were full of a
daycare that's all like them let me have
a brutal brutal and we're just on today
yes and they you being on top it's all
every day of four actually before and
one the morning was the end Caesar seven
they got dirty I didn't give a [ __ ] like
we're about to do right now Lee come
over here sit next to Yong chol you're
still got another I'm still burning this
[ __ ] come over here sit next helpfully
we're going off tonight who wants the
hotel's atiba
oh [ __ ] Bose headsets me the TV show you
know I brought your special blood
[Music]
the t-bird Dean is here and there's
uncle UT as I [ __ ] always do we come
through with the sativa for my Uncle
Dean it's not 24 cases it's a Mauser not
a sour OG yeah night he wasn't even
[Music]
the original travel I understand he
shows up with creatures poultry you know
you want desk dog or you want to Naylor
oxen are negated oh my god Robin can I
got everything here you forgot
everything you need at the buckle my
friend
come on down [ __ ] Larry we'll see
you tomorrow night in Viva Las Vegas
with a new gun and a [ __ ] target is
I'm saying I got a gun anyway let's do
this [ __ ]
now what I do I do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] it's that type of night tonight
if you had plans cats for those
[ __ ] because we're coming into
your living room full effect no [ __ ]
holds barred somebody's going to
hospital tonight
[Music]
over over over it suck that you will
suck that you suck that meal there you
go
oh wait quick quick and then we'll body
there you go quickest at it see nothing
happening to all because it is Uncle
John [ __ ] Bala network cards next
week
they got a bondage [ __ ] showdown
we're going through it understand I'm
bring a mound Weaver we're bringing all
[ __ ] Reaper write our own what
[Music]
take that to the [ __ ] Bank [ __ ] he
died
[ __ ] my med Pressman of New York City
at or NYC went to see the dead you did
everything on how the music's off the
leg so Vivian [ __ ] together gear phone
get your [ __ ] paper you might learn
some [ __ ]
don't forget stay loose next week coming
and having the ultimate sin then the
week after that two weeks after that
July 29th Billy Camden's and Salkin
or you crazy little [ __ ] suburbs get
ready to go New Jersey them house as
usual I don't want to hear you either no
tickets good or if you want to ticket
place you don't know god it'll [ __ ]
around Conti something that's it I got
the actual calculate you guys are
[ __ ] around Italy no tears later
anyway
food wants a bomb who said but I'm ready
to go
[Music]
all right [ __ ] we what's up
with that chocolates and office yeah a
tool a big empty good kaput it will
[ __ ] around right there and there's
more bags for debris muhammad's is there
he like competence to bring the Hamish
and alluding hundred and you take the
flavor all for the [ __ ] chocolaty
delicious of it you don't know much you
like we compete and make you know Oh
Jed's a millionaire and I'm sitting here
in my cave solo waiting for [ __ ]
producer you say open a factory get this
party started these ready to go here is
where you go when you sit around [ __ ]
wasted time you make [ __ ] Ted Bundy we
got stars coming up throw this away from
my uncle Joey Brian there's an album
Gino Castro family is crazy
oh yeah I need that storage tremendous
keynote address everything what I was
now we're going to do chocolate and star
we will do mm sighs I know you are good
a thousand stars apply one in chocolate
go no we do it you need to eat the
chocolate impressive sorry
we're going to break our record time we
want to the 3000 is the chocolate 235
music and you already got to analysis
why not
[Music]
you may collect on your own desire on
Victoria how to break your record lead
for 20 years but no breaking records for
the Guinness World Records for coming
neck another Guinness Book says you
gotta skillet Electr going to take the
chocolate no we do it in always coming
at you oh jesus [ __ ] christ with
depression
[Music]
oh what's in this bag
I think you director I think interaction
with you - oh my god oh Jesus Christ
I mean Oh
[Music]
CyberKnife people youtube.com / c / Joey
Diaz is the place to be [ __ ]
you got least I act Mauricio Alvarado
and my main [ __ ] man
my main [ __ ] man be Delray
freshly New York with none for
conversation
[ __ ] constant chitchat or we show the
well-known photography in the area
[ __ ] young kid to savage understand I
wouldn't have my little fuck-around
is going out
[Music]
to develop into singing youtube.com / c
/ Joey did you know we love your
[ __ ] without you we'd have
nothing we just hear [ __ ] around do
you not show these people what you got
there so what you got like a [ __ ]
eighth-graders turn around please I
ain't looking on the ropes already that
so long yeah that's good not better huh
whoo yeah look at this yesterday this is
where I posted a selfie of - joy this is
what I saw anyone read this tremendous
you bad [ __ ] I'm happy you're
here I'm happy you're part of my world
your world on the [ __ ] key they still
Madonna
[Music]
[Music]
I'm a man over here lease I am also down
some chocolate [ __ ] delicious just like
our first row
that's delicious - listen I got told you
next time bring the hummus we're going
to go for three chocolate bars on Monday
night our Sunday left I looked upon your
hummus and you can either be loving you
know we do it at the church he want to
talk if he loves like I'm I love I fear
if I didn't like the taste for this
chocolate I bring a container with an
ice cream while you die you don't make
and I dip the trunk in the vanilla ice
cream inside but you want mothers you
eat hummus every day you either every
day you rub it the stink comes out of
your neck with one of the chocolate and
then going to use so let's break this
record well factor I know
[Music]
walking man you haven't somebody that
[Music]
motherfucker's want to pawn me now I
call them a 20-amp anyone they want to
call me now or in the middle of a
[ __ ] tremendous periscope it leaves
about to finish the chocolate oh no no
that's just a little piece of ass I
believe them we split them in thirds
bring his twos take two bites you
swallow look at them he breaks the
Beatrice this one dealing with your
LaserJet his little black kids in Africa
right now about the Daigo I wish I wish
I'd had a piece of chocolate uncle Joey
shows about periscope
[Music]
something I guess I wanted my gun
I'll later into it Oh
[Music]
delicious
[ __ ] tremendous you understand me
it's good for your tummy we're having a
good time here I'm already three sheets
to the [ __ ] wind but I'll tell you
what I'm gonna do youtube.com slash
seats last Joey Diaz is the place to be
you know I love you [ __ ] I'll
see you in Vegas Friday night enjoy the
podcast stay black